in pictures in in Stills and in videos
for me I always knew that if you had a
good time and you really engaged with
somebody and you got lost and you
weren't afraid to be a fool and to be
Daft and to you know my responsibility
especially as I got older was I really
wanted to take care of the people who
were in the photograph with me I wanted
to make them comfortable with this girl
or a kid or baby or whatever else or
another man if you do that properly and
you do that with
genuine Integrity that transmits to the
person who's looking at that picture and
that's just the way it is and so I
always want to no matter how tired I am
no matter how worn out I am I want to be
present you know I want to be
I want to be real